we were just talking about lamello ball
and the gods have graced us with his
presence lamello ball now joining us on
the Tuesday show again 2021 rookie of
the year uh lamello thank you for
joining us you know you were named to
The Rising Stars last year but the game
didn't happen we didn't get to see you
at All-Star Weekend What can we expect
from you in Cleveland this year as you
go out there for All-Star Game
yeah hopefully a show I mean go out
there and have fun it's doing it with
everybody who want to leave right now so
I feel like it's going to be a great
time
the Mellow tracker three things one I'm
so proud of you uh two congratulations
and lastly now you remind me of a guy
his name is Penny Hardaway when he first
came into the league he had everything
so I asked Penny when he first came in
who did you model your game after of
course he said Magic Johnson so I'm
gonna ask you the same question who do
you model your game after
honestly myself I mean I go out there
and just try to be myself for real but
I've seen a lot of Jamal Crawford Penny
Hardaway too so that's crazy you say
that and yeah for real though a lot a
lot of Jamal Crawford I've seen him a
lot growing up but mostly video games
and stuff like that just seeing
everything they was doing there I'll go
outside try it again pretty much that's
how my whole game came to me
Bellow as a you know baby in the family
I know you're the baby in the family we
don't lack confidence so obviously
you've gone viral pointing at the half
court line pulling up and shooting so I
just want to tell you Shaq has 50k if
you point at half court and hit it from
the you know half court line in the
pricing stars games oh you got a hundred
all right so I got 100 for you I just
need 20 oh that's light that's what it's
played again 20 you got to hit it though
that definitely got to go for it
nowadays
I got I got a point too yeah you got a
point in high school one yep let's see
uh lamelo my question is you know
obviously we've we've watched you uh
since you I don't know how old you was
when we got an opportunity to first get
introduced uh to your family but we've
watched you grow up and we live in this
world right now where um we live in a
cyber bullying world where everyone has
an opportunity to comment and you know
say what they want about your game or
your family whatever how do you deal
with like what is your greatest personal
strength how do you deal with all the
things that's been said about you and
your family and still go out there every
night and compete at the level you
compete at um against the best to play
this game
uh I feel like pretty much just have my
pops raise me just never lose your
composure and just keep you know just
the family close so we just all talk to
each other and we don't really let
nobody come inside so we really never
cared when nobody said
new year new me same me though lamelo
ball you are the man uh congratulations
on the rising stars not and we can't
wait to see what you do in the league
going forward thanks lamelo thank y'all
y'all have a good one all right Melo
when I hit you up that was one of my
favorites 20 new year new me same name
you know we have